good morning believe nation today's
message is never believe a prediction
that doesn't empower you over to you
Sean Stephenson never believed a
prediction that doesn't empower you when
I was born the doctors told my parents
and I would be dead within the first 24
hours of my life 35 years later all
those doctors are dead
and I am the only doctor that remains
never believed a prediction that doesn't
empower you
how many predictions have been thrown at
you your whole life if you believe
predictions that do not empower you you
will wither away and die either
physically die or your spirit
will die as you just walk around the
world like a carcass that is just
following the masses you will be given a
lot of titles in your life you will be
told so many different things you must
only listen to that which empowers you I
have a belief that have served me in my
life and that is that everyone is
rooting for me to win even those that do
not know it I love this message because
a lot of people are going to make
predictions about you right a lot of
people are going to have their opinions
on how good you are and whether your
idea will work out or not and where you
should go in life and really the only
predictions that matter are the ones in
here in your head and not being not
having it filtered through other people
and because somebody else thinks that
you can't do it now sudden you take on
that prediction you feel like oh I can't
do it because this guy said so I call
asleep with a little man right we've
talked a lot about on this channel the
little man is a person who just throws
tomatoes at all your ideas doesn't
believe you can do it tells you all the
reasons why self is not gonna work out
and that the concept that little man
came from a guy in my life who when I
was getting my YouTube channel up and
going and one of the first kind of big
videos that I had that hit it the first
videos it went big when I was coming up
within the concept stage I showed it to
him and he said it's six minutes long
this video is way too long it's never
gonna work out you know I predict that
this video is gonna gonna go south and
and hurled insults at me like tell me
you actually understand how the internet
works and this guy actually had some
this guy wasn't just some no-name guy
that I asked on the subway and said hey
what do you think but I didn't let his
prediction hold me back cuz I could have
right I could have said oh well this guy
knows what he's talking about he doesn't
like it maybe I should change me I
should make it shorter maybe I shouldn't
put it up at all and start to doubt
myself but I looked at it myself and it
just felt right and I knew that people
would enjoy that
I enjoyed it it moved me and if it moved
me it'll move other people as well fast
forward to now it has over a million
views it's the belief by video that I
think a lot of you guys have seen and
and I'm so glad that I didn't listen to
him I didn't listen to the little man
but too often we do right how many times
have you had an idea that you're really
excited about it and you tell your
friends or your spouse or online people
or different communities or mentor and
they say nah that's not gonna work you
shouldn't do that you know here's why
it's not gonna work and the challenge is
because when you start a new idea when
you have a new plan there are holes
right you haven't figured it out yet
it's the start that's why I'm coming to
you asking for advice because I haven't
figured out the gameplan if I knew what
to do exactly then I just go and do it
and I wouldn't have to ask for any help
and so you know little minds a person
just points out all the problems and the
flaws but doesn't give you advice and
suggestions right where your friends and
the mentors the real Mensch ones are the
ones who identify those challenges and
then give you suggestions like this
might be a problem for you going forward
so why don't you try doing it like this
so here's a way to overcome that
obstacle right and that's how you start
to identify and understand who are the
people in your life who really support
you who really have your back really
want you to be successful and who are
the people just throwing their negative
predictions at you so I think it's
really important to not just filter in
the information that comes from other
people but listen to your heart first
and often the thing that your heart
tells you to do is something that other
people can't understand because they're
using their heads and you're trying to
create a world that doesn't yet exist
you have this big crazy bold idea to
have an impact on the world that hasn't
been done yet but anybody else and so
how are you going to logically how
people are going to understand that you
even know you like you trust you want to
help it doesn't make sense because
you're creating the world doesn't exist
yet but if you feel it in your heart and
you look at the thing that you created
or you look at the plan that you want
it burns up in you right it makes you
excited that fills you with passion and
excitement then you have to go and do it
and not listen to the people around you
and listen to that I get a predictions
and listen to the little man and all of
their hate and negativity so the
question they today is I'm really
curious about a prediction that somebody
made about you
that wasn't empowering and and I'd like
you to share it I know that might be a
little person a little vulnerable but I
think by sharing it one it releases it
from you and hopefully you don't hold on
to it anymore and two I think it can
also help inspire other people who are
watching this video and watching the
comments even if they don't leave a
comment they're watching it and knowing
that other people are facing the same
thing I think you can help so what's a
negative prediction somebody made about
you be honest leave in the comments
below and I'm going to during the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso